one for this uh
third uh session
of the day and we're going to talk today
and our first thing here with that
jacobs who is going to talk about some
algorithms to do our whole transport
cool thanks a lot um all right so
uh i guess most people here are
at least familiar with optimal transport
but um just really quick we have two
measures i want to find a map that's
going to send one of the measures
together and i'm just going to pay some
amount by how much i move this mass
and
right this problem has lots and lots of
applications um but it's really hard to
complete these maps
and so essentially that's the goal of
this algorithm is to accurately compute
optimal transport
so
um let me just show you guys my favorite
example
um and if you've seen me
talk about this before then you'll
recognize this
sorry
[Music]
so i have a silhouette of pikachu i have
a silhouette of raichu i want to find
the optimal transport map between them
um and these are both super large images
so in general this would be something
that's hard to compute
and what i'm going to show you guys is
basically once you've computed the map
between them you can create these really
cool
uh videos where you basically just send
each particle along the trajectory
and so this just kind of gives you a
nice
visualization of what's happening
when you solve some kind of optimal
transport problem
okay so
let me just quickly
say something
about uh how this algorithm works
um and the idea is we're just going to
solve the dual problem to optimal
transport
and they're essentially two equivalent
formulations of this dual problem
there
there's no reason to choose one over the
other
and so the idea is actually let's do
gradient ascent on both of the problems
um and so they're linked to each other
through this c transform and that's sort
of what um
this superscript c is representing so
phi c
is essentially kind of the same thing as
psi psi c is kind of the same thing as
five
and um
with this c transform you can switch
back and forth between these two
problems so we do gradient ascent on one
we switch to the other we do gradient
percent there and we just keep going
back and forth
um and so the c transform is this
non-linear transform
and that's why there sort of is a point
of working with both problems
so i would say in some sense right
gradient ascent is sort of linear
and you have this non-linear
transformation you can go through
and uh that's why you really gain
something um by working with both of
these
um
and uh it turns out you can actually
compute the gradient of these c
transforms
uh explicitly and uh this is like a
really important calculation that's due
to uh wilfred and uh robert mccann
um
and i would love to say a lot more about
this but there's really no time um so
let me just say a few other key details
so
my sort of perspective on solving
optimization problems
is you always want to think about it in
the continuous setting
and then discretize at the absolute last
moment
um
and so if you want gradient descent on
those problems to make sense
you have to do it in the h1 metric
and so this is like another
perspective right that we've seen of
like
doing these uh
optimization problems where you really
really want to care about
the metric that you use for gradient
design
and here h1
is the right metric
and the point is if you have
uh an infinite dimensional problem where
your optimization algorithm makes sense
then when you go to discretize it
um the convergence rate basically
doesn't depend on the problem size and
you can solve it
uh super quickly
um
and uh the c transform is actually
something you can compute efficiently
and that lets you uh solve these
problems on really large examples super
fast
um
so here's just another fun example
um i have a portrait of monge i'm going
to send it to a picture of kantorovich
this is what happens
again these are really high resolution
images
and you get these pretty nice results
[Music]
and uh let me just say we've also
applied this algorithm to w2 gradient
flows
i can't say too much about that but for
the pde people here
uh basically this is going to be a video
of
an incompressible flow so the
the yellow stuff um is the density
it's basically being attracted to some
potential that has a minimum
over here
and those white things are obstacles so
it's not allowed to touch them
and you get this really
kind of cool looking flow
and
the nice thing is that you preserve this
sort of sharp interface throughout the
flow and um the algorithm makes that
pretty easy to achieve
um
and did you play with the game oh yeah
um
and so uh let me just end by saying
there's a lot that i still want to do
with this and a lot that i still don't
understand
so we have heuristics of why doing this
back and forth thing makes things faster
but no actual rigorous mathematics so
that would also be really nice
and in fact we don't even have a
convergence argument for this algorithm
so we can show that basically one step
of gradient ascent should make things
better
uh but we don't actually have an
explicit rate
um
[Music]
and so everything i've shown you guys is
in 2d
um and so to do this c transform fast uh
we're really relying on a low
dimensional grid structure
so
i'm very interested to see if there's an
efficient way to do this
in high dimensions
and then there's also just lots of other
problems to apply it to
okay so let me stop there
question
can you tell us a little more what you
used to continue to see transform is it
your visit for any cost
so um you can do lt costs in on
operations on endpoints
and you use an f50 trigger and what do
you use it's uh
no it's just like a convex portrait
basically but it's very very dependent
um for more general costs if you can
separate it along each of the dimensions
then there actually is an f t trick that
does it in like margaret
yeah
yeah so what happens in the world this
is that case where the situation is very
easy but the potentials are not
sufficient for getting them back and
also
yeah so this works uh better for costs
that are strictly complex and so as you
go towards one or as you go towards
infinity uh basically that starts